now magnus continuing to harass that
queen and nakamura he sacrifices his
queen but we're going to see a night
fork
the black knight attacking the king
attacking the queen now nakamura two
pieces up
a knight and a bishop magnus he's going
to continue
he's playing on the rook attacks the
black bishop but we see on magnus's face
he's shaking his head he knows he's it's
over now he's lost
black simply has a knight and a bishop
white's pawns are not going to
suffice is it all over now
yeah magnus just going through the
motions the pawns are going to start
dropping off the board
two pieces it's just too much even if
white was able to trade the rooks
it would still be game over and knight
and bishop can give checkmate together
magnus just hoping for a last minute
blunder now pushing his pawns but it's
not going to happen
really nice tactic there by nakamura to
trade the queens that was
uh beautifully done and also done with
not so much time
i mean that was very very impressive and
yeah i agree with david it is absolutely
hopeless here i mean the bishop and
knight can
easily pick off those two corner pawns
that white has
and even with the trade of rooks the
position is still a very elementary
checkmate
i mean most people practice these uh
checkmating
patterns yeah the only hope for white
remaining is that
black will have to give up a knight or a
bishop for that
that pawn but nakamura so tricky
retreats the night
attacking white spawn if that pawn
advances then the black knight will jump
to the square the pawn currently stands
on
and that would be a fork that would be a
check to the white king and
it would also attack white's rook and i
don't think there's any way for magnus
to keep his pawn there
his a pawn and without it it's pretty
much game over he gives a check instead
he's going to drop his rook back
one square to defend his pawn from the
side
the rig will just come over and you can
see it's going to be rounded off
and do you think magnus is gonna make
hikaru play this
game loses he blunders his rook to
another night fork
and there we go magnus carson resigns